llevar el pan a la mesa es uno de los
mayores retos en afganistán la pérdida
de plazas de trabajo la falta de
efectivo por el colapso del sistema
bancario y finalmente la inflación
intensifica en la crisis alimentaria
esta situación que anteriormente
afectaba más a las zonas rurales ahora
impacta también a los sectores urbanos
nuestras encuestas revelan que nueve de
cada diez personas no tienen suficiente
para comer siete de cada diez están
utilizando estrategias extremas
en
el 50 por ciento de la población
experimenta quedarse sin alimentos al
menos una vez en las últimas dos semanas
en esta situación si tenemos que
afrontarlo necesitamos de 200 millones
de dólares para prepararnos antes de que
llegue el invierno de frankfurt de
formentera rayos
también escasean los medicamentos
generalmente importados desde pakistán
india bangladesh irán o turquía que ya
no se importan debido al cierre de los
cruces fronterizos y el acceso a los
bancos
desde la toma del poder los bancos están
cerrados al estar cerrados no podemos
transferir pagos a nuestros proveedores
y no podrán entregarnos los medicamentos
los precios subirán porque hay una alta
demanda y una baja oferta estamos
enfrentando una escasez en el suministro
de medicamentos esenciales como ejemplo
trabajan el erum analizamos la
astrología mientras el grupo talibán
continúa conformando su gobierno la
comunidad internacional sigue con su
mirada hacia afganistán por ello ha
prometido donaciones por más de mil
millones de dólares que aún no llegan